the harry potter film series put
together a seriously impressive ensemble
of young and established actors across
its eight films
here's what happened to many of your
favorites over the years
since the final harry potter film
released after a huge search to find a
young british actor to play harry potter
producers settled on daniel radcliffe
who was cast in the role at just 11
years old making him the perfect
age to play harry as he turns 11 and
heads to hogwarts
a young hero with an immeasurable burden
placed upon his shoulders
harry grows up constantly battling his
nemesis voldemort and
radcliffe who played the part through
all eight films
felt a huge sense of responsibility to
his character
even before the potter films came to an
end radcliffe put in the work to pave a
varied career path for himself to ensure
that he wouldn't be typecast as harry
forever
he made waves in 2007 when he landed the
difficult leading role of
equus on stage in london and new york
and has continued to act in major
theater productions
since hanging up his wand radcliffe has
also appeared in an eclectic array of
films that includes kill your darlings
swiss army man and guns akimbo as well
as the tbs series
miracle workers before harry arrives at
hogwarts he meets a student who will
prove to be one of the most
important people in his life ron weasley
oh boy bottoms up what's this
tonic for the nerves played by rupert
grant
ron becomes immediate friends with harry
ron proves to be an invaluable friend
and ally chosen from a huge group of
candidates grint
similar to radcliffe joined the potter
cast at a young age
and continued in his role for a decade
grin's first post potter project came in
2013
in the anti-war film into the white that
same year
he appeared in the biopic cbgb a few
years later he broke into television
with roles
in sicknote and snatch the latter of
which he executive produced
more recently grin starred in the apple
tv plus series
servant ron and terry have an amazing
friendship but they'd be absolutely
nowhere without their other best friend
hermione granger
played by emma watson the smartest witch
of her age hermione has an innate genius
and
intense work ethic that helps harry and
ron out of several different scrapes
and where ron is concerned it's more
than a friendship as the two eventually
marry
watson joined the franchise as a child
just like her counterparts and defined
the beloved character for legions of
fans
watson's post potter career has proven
quite successful
both as a performer and a public figure
along with roles in films like the perks
of being a wallflower
bling ring and the live-action remake of
beauty and the beast
watson serves as a goodwill ambassador
for the united nations and promotes
causes like literacy and
gender equality recently watson appeared
in director greta gerwig's 2019 take on
little women
and is still acting despite 2021 reports
that she had quietly retired
the producers of the potter films
brought together some of the most famous
british actors
in the business that list included dame
maggie smith who plays hogwarts
professor minerva mcgonagall
a strict yet fair teacher who also
serves as the head of gryffindor house
it is said to be the home
of a monster smith who was anointed at
dame by queen elizabeth ii in 1990
is one of the most venerated actresses
of her era known for her work in films
like 1969's the prime of miss gene brody
1978's california suite both of which
won
her an academy award her most notable
post potter film work comes from the
best exotic marigold hotel and its
sequel you can also catch smith on the
occasional tv series
she won three emmy awards for her role
as the imposing dowager countess
on the popular period drama downton
abbey
the world of harry potter is inhabited
by plenty of complex characters but
few are as fascinating as severus snape
played by alan rickman
turn to page 394.
as hogwarts potions master who harbors a
serious grudge against harry
snape comes off as a pretty typical bad
guy out of the gate
however as it turns out snape has
secretly given his entire life in
service to harry and ultimately winds up
a hero
snape's death is one of the saddest in
the series and tragically
the world lost rickman in 2016 not long
after his final turn as the double agent
after gaining international fame for his
role as the villain hans gruber in the
action classic
die hard rickman became one of the most
in-demand actors of his era
appearing in films like sense and
sensibility galaxy quest and love
actually among others
when the harry potter film franchise
began legendary irish actor richard
harris was the perfect choice to play
the wise
seemingly all-knowing albus dumbledore
who serves as the beloved headmaster of
hogwarts and eventually harry's mentor
and
parental figure sadly harris who made a
perfect dumbledore
wasn't destined to play the part for
very long a celebrated actor known for
his roles in 1992's western
unforgiven and the 2000 action drama
gladiator harris passed away in october
of 2002
after appearing in harry potter and the
chamber of secrets
that same year in the aftermath of
richard harris's passing
another talented irishman stepped up to
take over as dumbledore
sir michael gambon who made his debut in
2003's harry potter and the prisoner of
azkaban and
played the character for the remainder
of the franchise gambin's dumbledore was
a little less gentle than harris's
portrayal a particular scene in the
goblet of fire stands out
how did you put your name in the fire
that's one of the oldest students to do
it for you but gambin relished the role
portraying a man racked with self-doubt
and regret internally but confident and
cool on the outside a venerated actor of
the stage
and screen gambin earned a claim for his
work with the national theater
film roles ranging from 1989's the cook
the thief his wife and her lover
to 2010's the king's speech as well as
television projects like 2017's little
women
he retired from the stage in 2015 but
continues to appear in film
and television early on after
discovering the truth about who he is
harry meets another young wizard who
will be a thorn in his side for years
draco malfoy played by tom felton a
spoiled and pampered bully from a
wealthy high status family
draco spends his time picking on harry
ron
and hermione usually flanked by goons
and hangers on
by the time the battle of hogwarts is
raging he's fully allied himself with
voldemort
and his death eaters actively working
against harry
in the years since potter felton has
appeared in big-budget blockbusters like
2011's rise of the planet of the apes as
well as the independent films like
2018's ophelia
on the small screen you might remember
his performance in season 3 of the cw's
hit arrowverse series
the flash a shy and bumbling young
wizard when he arrives at hogwarts
neville longbottom played by matthew
lewis has an unassuming beginning
has anyone seen a toad a boy named
neville's lost one
however during his time at hogwarts he
grows into a determined and strong
young wizard by the final films neville
is leading the renegade group
dumbledore's army at hogwarts to fight
voldemort and
plays a crucial role in the battle of
hogwarts to take down the dark lord
lewis like his character has experienced
a pretty dramatic glow up
and has turned into a bonafide leading
man over the years
as a result he's racked up plenty of
film roles throughout his career
including in 2016's me before you and
2018's terminal
as well as some television appearances
briefly introduced in the first film but
flashed out in chamber of secrets
ron's normally vivacious and bright
younger sister ginny weasley
is played by bonnie wright she's
rendered more or less mute when she
meets harry
on whom she has an enormous crush not
only do the two eventually strike up a
romantic
relationship and half-blood prince they
get married and start a family after
harry finally defeats voldemort
since potter wright has continued
working as an actor on the stage
and screen but she has tended to focus
more on production and direction
she has been responsible for bringing
several films to screen
including separate we come separate we
go and medusa's ankles
harry and his friends don't meet ivana
lynch's luna lovegood
until harry potter and the order of the
phoenix but she certainly makes quite an
impression
luna becomes close with harry ron
hermione neville and jenny
with their bond intensifying after the
group takes on death eaters together
hungry i hope there's pudding
lynch a longtime potter fan who was a
devotee of the book series
was deemed perfect for the part by
producers after an open audition
and continued to play the role until the
franchise ended when it did
lynch stayed in the public eye but took
on fewer projects signing on for roles
like 2015's my name is
emily while taking breaks from acting to
focus on her environmentally friendly
makeup line
kinder beauty box one of the most
accomplished and versatile actors
working today
helena bonham carter was the ideal
choice to play the savage cruel death
eater bellatrix lestrange
whose devotion to voldemort borders on
the inappropriate
throughout her long and impressive
career bottom carter has ping-ponged
between period pieces like 1992's
howard's end
huge hits like 1999's fight club and
fantastical collaborations with former
partner tim burton
like 2007's sweeney todd bonham carter
has worked steadily for years but one of
her highest profile roles came in 2019
where she took on the role of the hard
partying princess margaret
on netflix's the crown voldemort doesn't
truly appear in the flesh for the first
three harry potter films as he hasn't
yet regained human form but thanks to
some loyal servants and dark magic he
returns to his full strength and goblet
of fire at the film's climax
played by rafe fines it might seem crazy
that jennifer lopez's love interest in
the 2002 romantic comedy made in
manhattan would go on to play the dark
lord voldemort but
finds has some serious range on the
heels of voldemort
fines appeared in the 2012 james bond
film skyfall as gareth mulroy and
later reprised the role in 2014 he
earned a claim for a starring role in
wes
anderson's grand budapest hotel recently
fine start alongside carrie mulligan in
the netflix original film
the dig when it came time to cast the
bombastic
over-the-top author and hogwarts
professor gilderoy lockhart
who makes his debut in chamber of
secrets there could be no other choice
than kenneth branagh when lockhart takes
over the position of professor of
defense against the dark arts
he's quickly revealed to be completely
inept despite his enormous ego
an award-nominated actor who trained at
and now leads the royal academy of
dramatic art
rana is a legend of the stage and the
screen
well known for adaptations of
shakespeare upon said
trespasser
an accomplished director in addition to
his work in front of the camera
rana has made time to helm projects like
the first thor film while continuing to
appear in films like 2017's dunkirk and
2020s tennis
some actors only appear in a single
potter movie but while david tennant
only popped up in goblet of fire he
certainly makes an impression as the
briefly seen but utterly disturbing
barty crouch jr a devoted follower of
voldemort
croach jr is disguised for most of the
film as
madai moody posing as the defense
against the dark arts teacher
until his disguise finally cracks by the
time he appeared in goblet of fire
tennant was already playing doctor who
on the bbc
afterward tenant changed tac with the
gritty british crime drama broadchurch
opposite olivia coleman marvel fans
likely remember tennant from his
terrifying turn as kilgrave in netflix's
marvel series jessica jones
he's also appeared in some recent
high-profile film projects including
2018's mary queen of scots
thanks to a curse inflicted by voldemort
the post of defense against the dark
arts
ends up with a new professor in the role
every year
during his third year the seat was
occupied by remus lupin
played by david thulis though lupin
remains tight-lipped about his personal
life at first
our heroes eventually uncover that he's
a werewolf lupin is forced out of the
job
but he remains committed to helping
fight against the rising darkness
when it comes to non-potter projects
thulis has kept busy over the years
appearing in big films like 2011's
warhorse 2014's the theory of everything
ends the 2017 blockbuster wonder woman
as aries more recently you may have
caught the list in the 2020 netflix film
i'm thinking of ending things when we
first see brendan gleason who plays
alistar maddie moody
he's not who he seems literally as he's
being impersonated by death eater barty
crouch jr
audiences finally get to meet him as his
true self in order of the phoenix but
when he appears in deathly hallows
tragically it's his final appearance by
the time he appeared in the potter films
gleason was already well known for his
roles in huge movies like 1995's
braveheart
and 2002's gangs of new york after the
film franchise ended
you may have caught him in 2014's edge
of tomorrow or the delightful 2017
comedy paddington 2.
all right we'll have time for the cozy
catch-up later we've got to get the hell
out of here
and soon there are plenty of family
connections within the cast of harry
potter but casual fans might not know
that the actor who portrays bill weasley
donald gleeson is the son of mad i moody
himself
brendan gleeson immediately after his
brief turn in the potter franchise
gleason appeared in leading roles in
2012's anna karenina adaptation
and richard curtis's sweet 2013 romantic
comedy about time
2015 was a pivotal role for this
talented young actor who appeared in the
sci-fi thriller ex-machina
and also made his debut in the star wars
sequel trilogy in the force awakens
he's also appeared in films like mother
and peter rabbit
in harry's third year at hogwarts he and
his classmates are introduced to
divination lessons
a course led by the wiffy unreliable
professor trelawny played by emma
thompson
while her confidence in her own skills
doesn't exactly match her output
she once made a very real prediction the
one that settles both harry and
voldemort's awful fate
emma thompson one of the most well-known
and influential british actors of her
time
plays the silly trolani to perfection
almost unrecognizable in enormous
glasses
and piles of shawls she has appeared in
a huge variety of different projects
since
including 2013 saving mr banks 2017's
beauty and the beast
and 2019's late night do you know what
i'm not gonna remember any of this so
here's what we're gonna do
um you're one two three
when harry first learns about sirius
black played by gary oldman
he believes that the man wanted by the
entire wizarding community
is a murderer who killed 13 people with
a single curse
however as harry gets to know the man
who turns out to be his godfather
he realizes that not only has sirius
been falsely accused of his crimes but
he's a kind and generous man
which makes it all the more tragic when
he's killed in front of harry in order
of the phoenix
gary oldman was already an enormous star
before harry potter
thanks to high-profile roles and films
like the fifth element and air force one
among many others after competing for an
oscar in 2012 for tinker taylor soldier
spy
the veteran finally won one in 2018 for
his portrayal of winston churchill in
darkest hour
voldemort may be the biggest bad in
harry potter but dolores umbridge
played by imelda staunton gives him a
run for his money
a devoted ministry employee desperate to
rise within the ranks umbrage ends up
placed at hogwarts to keep an eye on
dumbledore
and his supposed wrongdoings eventually
succeeding him
and becoming headmistress so silly of me
but it sounds
as if you're questioning my authority in
my own classroom
staunton was well-known pre-potter
thanks to roles in the 1998 best picture
winner shakespeare in love and 2005's
nanny mcphee
among many others after her time in the
potter films came to a close
you may have heard staunton in the
paddington films or seen her as a fairy
in maleficent
mistress of evil with angelina jolie
harry is bullied a lot in the series
and one of his first true enemies is his
cousin dudley dursley played by harry
melling
dudley is a spoiled child who's given
anything he wants by his indulgent
parents
and is a true terror for much of his
life though in the books and in a
deleted scene from deathly hallows part
1
dudley does show remorse for his
behavior towards harry in the years that
followed
melling shed the image of dudley and
worked on several high-profile projects
from 2018 to 2020 milling appeared in
three popular netflix films
the ballad of buster scruggs the devil
all the time
and the old guard but you might know him
best from his scene-stealing supporting
role in the beloved 2020 netflix
mini-series the queen's gambit
in which his character lends his love
and support to chess prodigy beth harmon
petunia dursley played by fiona shaw
forces her nephew harry to sleep in a
cupboard
under the stairs and generally abuses
him until he finally learns the truth
about his magical blood
after that revelation the dursleys avoid
and marginalize him as much as possible
never truly acknowledging him as a real
member of the family
fiona shaw was a legend of the british
stage before she took on the role of
petunia dursley and she continued
working steadily
after her potter years ended recently
shaw appeared in films like 2020's enola
homes and also found time for television
roles in popular shows like killing eve
fleabag and trueblood check out one of
our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite actors are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one